- Trans athletes and allies are fighting a surge of
proposed anti-transgender legislation across the U.S.
Many of these bills have aimed to ban trans athletes from
competing on teams that affirm their gender identities.
Trans girls and trans women
are the main targets of these bills,
with backers believing they have an unfair
advantage over cisgender competitors,
but trans rights advocates say
it's not about wins and losses.
Lindsay Hecox’s dream of running
cross-country for Boise State
was put on hold when Idaho passed
House Bill 500 in the spring of 2020.
Billie Jean King, Candace Parker, Megan Rapinoe
and almost 200 other athletes signed
an amicus brief speaking out against the law,
which has since been suspended.
This isn’t the first time the sports world has
pushed back against anti-trans legislation.
In 2016, the NBA and NCAA pulled
major events out of North Carolina
in response to a bill prohibiting trans people from
using public restrooms that matched their identities.
This contributed to the law's partial repeal in 2017.
But athletes like CeCé Telfer, the first out
trans woman to win an NCAA title,
want to see the organization take a
firmer stance on current legislation.
- As a trans athlete, first of all, I am not a threat
to women's sports because I am a woman.
- The NCAA has since stated host sites
must be "free of discrimination."
Trans students will also now be
protected under Title IX.
The surge of legislation is unprecedented,
but discrimination against trans, non-binary
and intersex people is not new.
Pride Month historically celebrates
and honors LGBTQ+ communities,
but activism against anti-trans legislation
reminds us of where Pride began:
in struggle and for visibility,
power, solidarity and equality.